nesse mundo onde os alimentos cada vez
mais se transformam em obras de
engenharia à medida que a vida se torna
mais sofisticada e conectada a qualidade
da nossa dieta parece seguir um caminho
inverso degradando-o a cada novidade
industrializada ironia das ironias hoje
enfrentamos um paradoxo onde o excesso e
a má qualidade dos alimentos se tornam
as maiores ameaças à saúde humana do que
a própria fome pessoal estamos imersos
em uma era que se orgulha de suas
conquistas científicas e de políticas
que prometem bemestar e saúde contudo
essa bela fachada esconde uma realidade
mais sombria algumas grandes corporações
do setor alimentício farmacêutico e
agrícola com seus tentáculos estendidos
em influência profunda deturpam esses
ideais elas moldam políticas manipulam a
opinião pública e exercem uma uma
pressão enorme sobre instituições
incluindo políticos e até instituições
educacionais como escolas médicas esse
domínio corporativo gerou um cenário
onde a confusão reina e as doenças
proliferam alimentadas por dietas
inadequadas e informações distorcidas
não é exagero dizer que estamos
Navegando em um mar de incertezas e
desinformações pensem comigo quantas
vezes nos deparamos com informações que
na correria do dia a dia do cotidiano
acabamos aceitando Sem questionar Esse é
o solo fértil para Minas verdades
interpretações distorcidas e quando o
assunto é saúde e alimentação ah aí o
cenário fica ainda mais nebuloso estudos
e pesquisas muitas vezes são como
quebra-cabeças incompletos e nós na
falta de peças ficamos com apenas um
fragmento da realidade o resultado são
meias verdades que transformam nossa
alimentação fazendo que a gente abandone
certos alimentos saudáveis ou pior
incluir outros que nem seriam
necessários e que são desastrosos paraa
nossa saúde hoje o ovo é vilão amanhã é
herói e nós ficamos perdidos em meio a
esse bombardeio de informações
contraditórias e é isso que vamos
desmascarar nesse vídeo as grandes
mentiras alimentares que deixam você
doente vamos ao item um primeira mentira
cuidado a gordura saturada faz mal na
década de 60 a indústria do açúcar fez
um movimento digno de um mestre de
xadrez pagou cientistas para jogarem a
culpa das doenças cardíacas nas gorduras
saturadas enquanto o verdadeiro vilão o
açúcar saía de fininho como quem não
quer nada a astúcia foi tamanha que
conseguiram publicar um estudo em uma
das revistas mais respeitadas o New
England Journal of medicine agora Pense
Comigo quantas vezes no nos foi dito
para evitar a gordura saturada como se
fosse a peste Enquanto isso o açúcar era
apenas calorias vazias eles literalmente
compraram a verdade e Venderam uma
mentira Quem pagou por isso nós por
décadas as diretrizes alimentares
colocaram o açúcar Isso inclui os
carboidratos refinados em um pedestal
enquanto demonizam as gorduras saturadas
e o resultado uma epidemia de obesidade
e doenças cardíacas a a gordura saturada
é um tipo de gordura que é sólida a
temperatura ambiente sendo encontrada
principalmente em alimentos de origem
animal como é o caso da carne bovina dos
ovos manteiga frango leite e iogurte
além disso a gordura saturada também
está presente em boas quantidades em
alimentos de origem vegetal é o caso do
Óleo de coco do azeite e do amendoim a
mania do baixo teor de gordura das
últimas décadas acompanhou o aumento
dramático do obesidade cílio metabólica
diabetes tipo 2 e doenças cardíacas
quando as empresas alimentícias
retiraram a gordura natural dos produtos
ela foi substituída pelo açúcar ou
gorduras artificiais criadas em
laboratórios os supermercados logo
ficaram inundados de produtos
proclamando serem baixos em gorduras
como Light ou bom para o coração no
entanto o que não contaram para nós é
que a gordura saturada longe de ser a
vilã da história na verdade tem um papel
crucial ela nos deixa satisfeitos reduz
apetite e o mais surpreendente não é a
causa do ganho de peso uma revisão
abrangente das pesquisas sobre gordura e
peso chegou a uma conclusão
surpreendente a gordura saturada não é o
que nos faz engordar outra análise
meticulosa de mais de 72 estudos
envolvendo mais de 600.000 pessoas
revelou uma verdade surpreendente
não existe uma ligação concreta entre o
consumo de gordura saturada e as doenças
cardíacas esses casos se tornaram um
exemplo clássico de como a indústria
alimentícia pode mudar a nossas
percepções e crenças sobre a comida
agora com as evidências que temos
sabemos que as gorduras saturadas não
são as vilãs e sim são parte essencial
de uma dieta equilibrada e você é novo
por aqui aqui inscreva-se junte-se ao
nosso grupo de saúde gostou do vídeo
deixe seu like compartilhe essas dicas
valiosas no seu WhatsApp nas suas redes
sociais com seus amigos familiares com
seus contatos para promover saúde e
informação de qualidade o item dois a
mentira número dois o colesterol é o
vilão e os ovos não são saudáveis porque
aumenta o colesterol é incrível como um
alimento tão simples e nutritivo pode
ser tão mal compreendido a ideia de que
os ovos são ruins pro coração e aumenta
o colesterol é uma das maiores falácias
que já circularam na medicina imagina só
proibir um alimento tão completo e
acessível por anos os ovos foram vistos
como vilões acusados de aumentar o LDL o
colesterol ruim entre aspas e
recentemente estudos como publicado na
nutrients estão mostrando que na verdade
os ovos são os heróis podem ser os
heróis em nossas dietas agora imagine
isso o ovo esse alimento básico humilde
que foi tão mal interpretado na verdade
não só é inofensivo como também benéfico
estudos mostram que os ovos podem entar
o HDL o bom colesterol e não estão
associados ao aumento do risco de
doenças cardíacas e não estão associadas
à obesidade ele é rico em adiponectina
um hormônio que auxilia na perda de peso
Além disso é um excelente aliado para
quem busca saciedade ajudando anda a
controlar a fome por mais tempo é como
descobrir que o patinho feio é na
verdade um cisne primeiro é importante
entender que o colesterol é essencial
pro nosso metabolismo corporal ele
desempenha funções vitais como a
produção de hormônios que é uma das
funções fundamentais dele e um fato
interessante a maior parte do colesterol
presente no nosso organismo é produzido
pelo próprio organismo e não vem da
alimentação isso já nos faz questionar a
ideia de que alimentos como os ovos são
prejudiciais nesse aspecto o que muitos
não sabem é que o verdadeiro problema
não é o colesterol em si mas sim uma
forma específica dele que é o LDL
oxidado e é essa a forma de colesterol
que pode contribuir paraas doenças
cardíacas é que vai outra informação
importante comer ovos não tem relação
com o aumento de triglicerídeos no
sangue que esses sim são de fato um
fator de risco para doenças cardíacas
na verdade os trigliceridos são afetados
pelo consumo excessivo de carboidratos
refinados e açúcares não pelos ovos em
si portanto na próxima vez que você
ouviu alguém dizendo que ovos são ruins
pro colesterol lembre-se de que este é
um mito que já foi desmentido já foi
derrubado pela ciência mentira número
três o óleo canola é a opção mais
saudável para cozinhar a história do do
Óleo canola é bem intrigante e revela
muito sobre as complexidades da
indústria alimentícia o óleo canola tem
suas raízes na planta cousa que
inicialmente era usada como lubrificante
de motores durante a segunda guerra
mundial como a guerra havia acabado eles
tiveram a Brilhante ideia de transformar
esse subproduto de guerra em alg
comestível Então os cientistas do Canadá
trabalharam arduamente para alterar
geneticamente a planta da cousa o
objetivo era reduzir os níveis de ácido
erúcico que era tóxico irritante paraas
membranas mucosas do corpo humano assim
nasceu na década de 70 o óleo canola
inicialmente promovido como óleo natural
mas a história não para por aí em 1995 a
Monsanto introduziu uma versão
geneticamente modificada do Óleo canola
rapidamente Esse óleo modificado dominou
o mercado em 2005 87% da canola era
geneticamente modificada em 2009 essa
porcentagem subiu para 90% do Canadá
apesar de aprovado por órgãos
reguladores como fda e envisa o óleo de
canola é cercado de controvérsias não
apenas por ser um produto transgênico
mas também devido a estudos que associam
o seu consumo a problemas de saúde como
lesões fibróticas no coração câncer de
pulmão e sí metabólica especialmente em
pessoas com sobrepeso ou obesidade a
longo prazo o consumo de óleo canola tem
sido associado a efeitos
adversos não apenas na composição
corporal e no risco de desenvolver
síndrome metabólica mas também na saúde
cerebral Lembra quando eu falei que o
LDL oxidado que é o vilão e não
colesterol em si por sofrer um processo
de oxidação em altas temperaturas o óleo
canola assim como de soja milha e
girassol proporciona o acúmulo de
colesterol LDL oxidado em nosso corpo
que é particularmente preocupante Pois é
considerado mais prejudicial para as
artérias o LDL oxidado tem uma tendência
maior a se acumular nas paredes das
artérias contribuindo paraa formação de
placas
ateroscleróticas essas placas podem
aumentar o risco de doenças
cardiovasculares incluindo ataques
cardíacos e derrames mentira número
quatro sal faz mal e você deve reduzir
ou retirá-lo da sua dieta o sódio ou sal
tem sido outro Bode expiatório das
doenças cardíacas há muito tempo sempre
nos alertam pros perigos do Sol dizendo
para consumirmos no máximo uma colher de
chá por dia acreditam que isso reduz a
pressão arterial e diminui o risco de
doenças cardíacas e AVC Mas essa é só
uma parte da história na verdade reduzir
o sal pode tanto baixar quanto aumentar
a arterial um estudo mostrou que cortar
o sal afeta as pessoas de maneiras
diferentes com cerca de 15% vendo
aumento na pressão e 18% uma redução
enquanto a maioria não sente diferença
reduzir muito o sal pode ativar
hormônios que endurecem as artérias o
oposto do que queremos hormônios do
estresse que aumentam a frequência
cardíaca também sobem com menos sal na
dieta elevando o risco de problemas
cardíacos e não para por aí de dietas
com pouco sal podem fazer o corpo
aumentar a insulina o hormônio que
armazena gordura aumentando o risco de
obesidade também podem levar a
resistência à insulina pré-diabetes até
hipertensão arterial justamente o que se
espera evitar bem a verdade é que quando
falamos na pressão alta é importante
saber que o consumo excessivo de açúcar
e carboidratos refinados esses sim podem
contribuir para hipertensão o açúcar
aumenta a resistência à insulina e o
ganho de peso ambos elevando a pressão
arterial Além disso afeta a retenção de
só e água nos rins aumenta o volume
sanguíneo e a pressão também precisamos
estar atentos à deficiência de outros
minerais como potássio e magnésio que
favorecem a regulação da pressão
arterial assim como prestar atenção ao
nível de hidratação se você tiver uma
boa hidratação consumir sódio potássio e
magnésio em equilíbrio seu corpo não vai
reter tanta água o que significa que seu
coração não irá precisar se esforçar
tanto menos retenção de água menos
chance de pressão alta Viu como não é só
uma questão de muito ou pouco sal Então
apesar de nos dizerem que menos sal é
sempre melhor não é tão simples assim um
equívoco comum na nossa alimentação
diária é ideia de que o sal que
adicionamos às nossas refeições
saudáveis é o principal vilão quando se
trata de consumo de sódio na realidade o
maior problema reside nos níveis
excessivos de sódio presentes em
alimentos processados e industrializados
o verdadeiro culpado aqui são os
refrigerantes repletos de sódio açúcar
assim como a miríade de outros alimentos
empacotados que muitas vezes consumimos
sem perceber o quanto de sódio açúcar
eles contêm para fazer escolhas mais
saudáveis é recomendável optar por sais
integrais como o sal marinho integral o
sal Celta ou sal rosa do Himalaia esses
tipos de sal são menos refinados e
mantém mais dos seus minerais naturais
em comparação com sal de cozinha comum
altamente refinado repensar o consumo de
sal não significa eliminar completamente
da dieta mas sim escolher opções mais
naturais e utilizá-las de forma
equilibrada nas comidas
mentira número cinco você precisa de
leite para ter ossos fortes o leite
parece ser o alimento perfeito da
natureza mas apenas se você for um
bezerro nós humanos somos os únicos
seres da natureza que continuam a beber
leite depois da Infância e não é
qualquer leite mas de outra espécie
parece um trama de ficção científica não
é mas é a nossa realidade A verdade é
que embora nos tenham vendido a ilusão
do leite como a chave para ossos fortes
e saúde duradora a realidade é um pouco
mais complexa e quando eu digo complexa
eu quero dizer que talvez tenhamos sido
um pouco enganados O leite pode ser um
vilão disfarçado para muitos de nós ele
causa inflamação alergias problemas
respiratórios irritações na pele e até
mesmo osteoporose diabetes e certos
tipos de câncer que T sido associados ao
seu consumo exagerado e é irônico não é
o alimento que deveria fortalecer nossos
ossos pode na verdade
enfraquecê-los não importa Quais
mensagens você ouça do Lobby das
Indústrias produtos láctos não promovem
ossos saudáveis pessoal em uma grande
metanálise o leite não reduziu o risco
de fraturas e outros estudos mostraram
que o consumo excessivo pode aumentar as
taxas de fraturas Aí temos uma outra boa
questão os países com menor consumo de
leite apresentam menor risco de
osteoporose e fratura
curioso não é mesmo o cálcio não é tudo
que dizem ser o excesso de leite pode
não apenas criar um desequilíbrio de
cálcio no corpo mas também afetar a
absorção de outros minerais essenciais
como o magnésio que também é importante
pros ossos estamos em um barco que
supostamente deveria nos levar à saúde
mas parece que estamos Navegando em
Águas turbulentas pessoal não se enganem
com mensagens encantadoras do Lob da
indústria dos laticínios a saúde óssea
não se resume ao único alimento ou
mineral é um coral sinfônico de muitos
nutrientes trabalhando em harmonia
precisamos de cálcio magnésio vitamina
K2 fósforo manganês
boro e precisamos de proteínas e
vitamina D entre outros Esses são os
verdadeiros Heróis na construção de
ossos fortes algumas das melhores fontes
de cálcio e da maioria desses outros
nutrientes que Eu mencionei incluem
vegetais ves como brócolis quiabo coua e
agrião amêndoas Gergelim grão de bico e
sardinha mentira número seis a pirâmide
alimentar é a maior mentira de todas
vocês se lembram dela não é mesmo aquele
gráfico que aprendemos na escola que
parece ter todas as respostas sobre o
que devemos comer mas e se eu dissesse
que essa pirâmide alimentar na verdade
contribuiu para uma série de problemas
de saúde Vamos começar com um fato
interessante e alarmante desde que a
primeira ideia da pirâmide alimentar foi
difundida nos Estados Unidos na na
década de 80 a obesidade disparou seria
coincidência eu acho que não a
verdadeira origem da pirâmide alimentar
é um enredo digno de um Thriller ela foi
concebida não por razões de saúde mas
como um jogo de xadrez político
econômico criada para satisfazer os
interesses de poderosos conglomerados
agrícolas de milho soja e trigo que na
beira da Falência estavam buscando
desesperadamente resgatar a
lucratividade essa estratégia foi
habilmente orquestrada para angariar
votos nas eleições manipulando a balança
do poder político e dominando o cenário
da exportação de alimentos globalmente
no entanto o preço dessa manobra
política foi alto e pago pela saúde
pública um aumento alarmante em doenças
crônicas como diabetes obesidade
depressão esteatose hepática e um pico
acentuado nos casos de infarto um
verdadeiro reflexo de como decisões
distantes das necessidades de saúde pode
desencadear um tsunami de consequências
negativas na saúde da população a
pirâmide oficial de 1992 que foi
amplamente adotada incluindo
posteriormente no Brasil colocava os
carboidratos refinados como pães massas
arroz e cereais na base nos disseram
para comer entre se a 11 porções desses
alimentos por dia e qual o problema
disso eles se decompõem e aoca no corpo
sendo armazenados como gordura agora
Imagine o que acontece quando consumimos
diariamente quase 25 kg de açúcar e
grãos refinados combinados estamos
falando de uma verdadeira bomba paraa
saúde e não para por aí a pirâmide
também nos aconselhou a consumir
gorduras e óleos com muita moderação
demonizando as gorduras saturadas a
recomendação de restringir gorduras e
óleos foi outro grande equívoco dessa
abordagem se você estiver Atento e
acompanhou discussão até o momento
percebeu porque essa pirâmide alimentar
pode ser considerada letal tudo começou
com a demonização injusta das gorduras
naturais embora a pirâmide tenha se
tornado um ícone da nutrição nas décadas
passadas Até recentemente nenhum estudo
avaliou a saúde das pessoas que adotaram
a sua recomendação e diretrizes uma
série de motivos levou à elaboração de
uma nova pirâmide de 2013 adicionando na
base os carboidratos inte inte grais
pães e arrozes integrais juntamente com
óleos vegetais o que ajudou pouco a
mudar a situação pessoal a pirâmide que
deveria ser a correta coloca as gorduras
saudáveis e os vegetais no alicee da
nossa alimentação agora eu quero propor
algumas perguntas a pirâmide alimentar
promovida pela indústria atualmente
contribui para as doenças modernas e as
inverdades que desvendamos como afetam a
saúde das pessoas Estou ansioso para
conhecer suas opiniões sinceras sobre
isso muito obrigado pela sua atenção um
grande abraço um beijo no seu coração
Você é
fera